[Música]
hubo un primer hecho que pasó casi
desapercibido el 27 de febrero del 2011
un joven en moto fue violentamente
abatido por policías cerca del principal
mercado de damasco de manera inédita
esta violencia provocó una manifestación
en el corazón de la capital siria el
ministro del interior se desplazó al
centro de la ciudad para calmar a las
masas el altercado se terminó
rápidamente pero los diplomáticos
estadounidenses presentes en la capital
siria advirtieron a washington que la
primavera árabe iba a contagiar también
a siria
a esta altura en túnez egipto los
presidentes ben ali y mubarak ya habían
sido derrocados algunos días más tarde
en marzo tuvo lugar el conocido episodio
de ver a unos niños pintaron un grafiti
con un mensaje anti bashar assad en el
muro de una escuela tu hora se acerca
doctor decía el texto
tras ello fueron detenidos y torturados
los padres pidieron la liberación pero
el gobernador de la provincia un primo
del presidente les habría respondido
olvide los y vayan a buscar a sus
esposas ellas les darán otros hijos y si
ustedes no son capaces traigan las
nosotros lo haremos por ustedes
nunca se ha comprobado la veracidad de
estas palabras pero esta historia dio la
vuelta al país y encendió la pólvora en
síria el terreno estaba fértil para una
revolución años de restricciones una
sequía que impactó duramente a la
población una parte del campo se volcaba
cada vez más hacia la región entonces el
pueblo se levantó enormes
manifestaciones pacíficas se sucedieron
a lo largo y ancho del país y el régimen
respondió con una sangrienta represión
desde el verano del 2011 la oposición
comenzó a tomar las armas poco a poco la
revolución se transformó en una guerra
civil empezaron a circular sospechas
sobre el uso de armas químicas en
washington barack obama hizo una
declaración que sorprendió hasta sus más
cercanos colaboradores alguna línea roja
para nosotros sería que empecemos a ver
un montón de armas químicas moviéndose o
siendo utilizadas eso cambiaría mi
cálculo el 21 de agosto del 2013 ataques
masivos con gas sarín golpearon la
periferia de damasco la oposición y
occidente acusaron al régimen y asegura
de 1500 personas había muerto eeuu con
el apoyo de francia se preparó para una
acción militar en siria
está lista para castigar a aquellos que
tomaron la decisión infame de gasear
inocentes pero último minuto barack
obama se desistió rusia aprovechó la
ocasión para aumentar su apoyo al
régimen y enviar soldados bashar assad
recibió también el apoyo de irán y del
hezbollah libanés la oposición se
desmoronó se debilitó y los islamistas
ganaron terreno antes de verse ellos
también debilitados hace diez años todos
vaticinaron la caída inminente de bajar
a la sal pero hoy está todavía en el
poder y nadie parece estar en
condiciones de cazarlos